♪♪
I loved that the writers didn’t
back away from showing two women
just not getting along.
And that’s fine, that’s real.
Gonna let you guys
get back to it.
I’m supposed to listen to her?
I have sweaters older than her
Stella, she’s the new
generation coming up.
So Alex I think feels Inferior.
She feels like this
woman wants her out of there.
But Greta
(sighs)
I love her.
Isn’t it sort of antiquated to
try and nail this
thing down so firmly?
Isn’t sexually fluid a thing?
Is that what you’re
saying you are?
I love the scenes between
Bradley and Laura.
Where Laura’s trying
to pressure her to define it.
The feelings emerge and maybe
you don’t know what they are.
I think that’s so
beautifully written.
I think what Bradley sees in
Laura is a woman
who really pushes her to examine
the truth about herself.
I’m...
Is Bradley willing to make the
personal compromises
necessary to really be a
star in this space?
And give up some of
her sense of self.
Or is she gonna go her own way?
Even if that blows up the show.
I still don’t, I don’t
understand why it’s a bad thing
for me to call something my
spirit animal.
Okay, and by the way, a whole
week went by and nobody cared.
Well, they care now.
We’re all from different
backgrounds, different,
you know, ethnicities, races
and having to deal with an issue
of cultural appropriation
and the prejudices that they
each have towards each other.
I thought that was
was fascinating.
There are strong
perspectives that differ on
how race is handled, how social
justice should be handled.
I’m so genuinely grateful that
we can show all the complexities
I think that Stella would prefer
you think that she’s blind to
your charms than she’s a bigot.
The beauty of the writing,
if you can watch an episode
and you can have five different
opinions about translating
the intention of these
characters,
or what is this really about?
We ask the audience if you see
yourself in that,
are you cheering along side
Daniel singing that song?
And then you realize, oh shoot
was that minstrelsy?
It’s a beautiful way of
asking our audience
to start having conversations.
When push comes to shove
and we get to this
sort of climactic place,
that’s when we really see who
you are and that you have to
reevaluate everything.
It’s an honor to play a
character who’s discovering
things about America
and the world.
As you, yourself, are having
that conversation.